hey here's something really funny and
embarrassing Donald Trump can't seem to
get people to go to his inauguration and
he's so desperate to get people there
but he's just offering random people on
Facebook the opportunity to go to the
event he can't get people to sing he had
to start offering foreign singers the
opportunity to perform more Democrats
than ever say they're not going I think
it's something like one-fifth of
congressional of House Democrats are not
going to be inauguration to total train
wreck
and now Trump is doing Facebook videos
to get people to go here's the post and
then we'll play a little bit of the
video Trump wrote or you know whoever
posted this would you like an invite to
the inauguration or welcome concert and
inaugural inaugural swearing-in ceremony
president alike president-elect Trump
wants to personally invite you to the
inaugural welcome concert and inaugural
swearing-in ceremony you will receive a
limited-edition commemorative ticket as
a keepsake to frame and remember this
historic event click here to register
for your tickets let's watch and listen
to some of the clip not a common problem
that presidents elect have getting
people to go to their inauguration the
inauguration is our moment in American
history and I want you to be with me
on Inauguration Day January 20th at the
mall it's going to be so exciting right
most importantly we're going to make
America great again I'll see you on
January 20th
yeah
to give you sex about pathetic this is a
DC councilmember said a few days ago
that they received 200 bus parking
permit applications for the Trump
inauguration oh okay well it's an
interesting number for context they've
received 1200 bus parking permit
applications for the women's March
protests the day after the inauguration
six times more bus applications for the
protest to Trump's inauguration than for
the inauguration itself and of course
yet another singer has backed out first
it was Paul Anka who all of a sudden had
a scheduling conflict then it was
country singer Jennifer Holliday who
said I'm backing out to stand with my
LGBT fans and then Andrea Bocelli the
classical Italian tenor backed out
that's predictable if you're an Italian
classical tenor your bread probably
isn't buttered by trumpets and alt
writers don't you think maybe an Italian
baritone would go along with it yeah
don't ever how can trump sweeten the
deal maybe 10% off Trump University if
you're willing to sit through the
inauguration or something like that you
can't you really can't write this stuff
can you know when somebody sent me the
facebook video I thought it must be like
a dubbed where Trump is really talking
about how much he loves Hispanic food or
something like that and it's been dubbed
where he's saying come to the
inauguration but no he literally posted
hey come to the inauguration tickets are
free and apparently about him 1 million
people are expected to show up its
inauguration but you have to wonder how
many of those people are going to be
protesters yeah especially because Trump
lost the popular vote by 3 million votes
and it's in this liberal bubble of DC I
bet a lot of people coming from the
outside are going to be against him oh
yeah and the police presence is going to
be heavily militarized don't don't
mistake that for a second so I don't
know I guess my message to the audiences
it seems like tickets are available if
you're interested in going and I have
some friends that are going down there I
think Ben Dixon didn't Ben mention to us
when he saw him that he was going to go
down those plans are in the works yeah
I'm curious what he's going to see an
experience there you'd have to give me
more than 10% off Trump University for
me to go if I got to get like 15% off
that scam the University maybe I'd
consider going that'd be quite the deal
and you know that walk that they
often do from the Capitol to the White
House down Pennsylvania Avenue yeah I'd
imagine that it's just not going to be
safe enough for him to be able to do
that you think I mean there were other
safety concerns for President Obama
around that as well where I remember he
wanted to walk outside of the limo and
Secret Service didn't want anybody got
out and he did it with you general I
don't remember if his daughters were
there there's always some security
concerns around around it but maybe they
would be bigger for Trump I don't really
know discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
read it that's our EDD i.t cruisin on
past 2200 of our viewers and listeners
discussing politics and all sorts of
other stuff with us there
check it out david pakman.com slash read
it back after this Warby Parker is
offering a free five day home Tryon to
give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses I personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home Tryon of five
pairs of glasses you can get your free
home try on and support the david pakman
show at Warby Parker trial dot-com /
TDPS
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I liked the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing